in a recent video I described the
benefits of training across modalities
of combining kettle bells gymnastic
rings powerlifting calisthenics animal
movements bodybuilding steady-state
cardio high-intensity interval training
all in a single training program each
method brings different benefits that
can complement the others making this a
superior way to build overall
performance that video got a better
response than I was expecting and it
seems a lot of you out there liked the
approach but a question that came up a
lot in the comments was how surely
combining kettle bells with powerlifting
with high-intensity interval training
will result in overtraining burn out an
injury or at the very least leave you
with no time to do anything else well
actually I don't see the problem the aim
here is not to perform an entire
bodybuilding leg day followed by a
calisthenics leg day followed by a day
of heavy squats or to be buying that all
into a single workout instead we'd
create a leg day or a full-body split by
cherry-picking the best exercises from
each discipline for our goals and of
course you don't have to work with every
one of those modalities either you can
pick just two or three as you like often
that might mean using kettlebells or
bodyweight training as accessories to
improve our strength on the big lifts or
it might mean doing some isolation work
on a leg curl machine to strengthen the
hamstrings at a particular range of
motion or it could mean combining
different exercises heavy squats
followed by pistol squats followed by
Cossack squats followed by weighted
lunge walks followed by kettlebell
swings followed by calf jumps with a
quasi isometric squat to finish this way
we're training max strength with heavy
squats
single leg strength with pistol squats
mobility and movement in the frontal
play with the Cossack squat ballistic
strength muscle endurance and hip hinge
with the kettlebell swings strength
endurance with the lunge walks an
isolated calf strength of the calf jumps
across the isometric squat builds great
control awareness and mobility and
serves as the perfect cool-down
opportunity as well as a way to perform
a moving meditation of course we'll be
doing less of each movement in fact I'll
rarely do three sets of anything but
this is hardly a problem when I'm moving
straight on to another movement the
targets many of the same muscles the key
is to place the most intense compound
and difficult movements first and to
gradually move towards the easier ones
that are more isolated that involves
slower twitch muscle fiber or that may
even be a towards cardio this reduces
injury
and ensures that you're able to perform
the most challenging movements whilst
you're fresh improving gains and
progress it's essentially reverse
pyramid training but where the weight
isn't the only deciding factor it's very
important that you listen to your body
here and we can take this even further
with a mechanical drop set that
incorporates different movements into a
single set moving straight from one
movement to the other as soon as you
reach technical failure for example you
might perform as many bench presses as
you can on a specific weight then
immediately start doing push ups
this provides you with the benefits
opposed to bench press the building max
strength and the push up for building
strength endurance and pump I also like
to vary cadence and intent in a single
set switching from slow quasi isometrics
to plyometrics and everything in between
I call these dynamic drop sets and you
can check one out in my recent video on
a push-up routine this is also a great
way to incorporate strategies to make
common movements more difficult so for
example if you want to train your finger
strength and fingertip push-ups are
ideal of course if you only do fingertip
push-ups then you won't be able to
challenge your pecs and shoulders all
that much because you'll give up before
you get to that point the solution is to
start the set on your fingers and simply
switch to regular push-ups once that
becomes too uncomfortable as for cardio
I like to use assistance cardio
movements to keep the pressure on the
same area so if I just did that shoulder
workout of some sort and I end by doing
a Tabata battle-ready protocol this
sends all the blood to the area just
trained helping it to recover and grow
and also building a huge insane pump
then there's the option of breaking your
workouts up throughout the day which
I've also talked about very recently and
this lends itself perfectly to this kind
of training if you have a six hour gap
between the heavy squat and the pistol
squat then you go be able to perform the
pistol squats without dealing with
Apetit from the heavy squat that way you
filt strength control balance and
endurance and more then in the evening
you might be some kettlebell swings for
endurance and pump this is also where
the incidental training can come in
training things throughout the day for
instance I might take five minutes
whilst my computer loads to perform some
handstand holds against the door seeing
as my main goal is the prior section and
balance that little bits of greasing the
groove is enough and it would
my shoulder strength for further
workouts later in the day this regular
movement also helps to keep my energy
levels up as I discussed recently when
it comes to selecting the movements
choose those that offer maximum bang for
the buck
those are movements that provide
multiple benefits rather than just one
hitting the heavy bag for instance is a
great form of cardio as is the rowing
machine but the heavy bag will let you
work on your technique and even increase
your mobility if you're throwing kicks
too it's up to you if you want to use
this with full body training bro splits
or push-pull legs but lately I've been
experimenting with what I call prime
focus workouts
these are full-body routines but with a
little extra emphasis on one particular
body part attribute or skill so I might
do a lot for the pecs but still hit
every other muscle group gently
throughout the rest of the day hopefully
that all makes sense if it sounds a bit
complicated then of course it can check
out my ebook and training program super
functional training which provides a
detailed routine that works just like
the one I've described here with a lot
more explanation as to how all that
works I also explained how you can cycle
between different training styles
without losing your gains and build up
the resilience you need by strengthening
connective tissue first this is a better
way to start out to many people seeing
as it's much easier to regain attributes
later on alternatively take a moment to
think about the attributes you would
like to Train whether that means finger
strength rotational strength max
strength endurance balance memory or all
of those things together then look into
the type of training you need to do to
improve in each one of those areas and
then swap them in or bolt them on to a
workout as appropriate this is a modular
approach and it allow Dee to pick and
choose the kind of things you want to
train so I hope you found this video
useful interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like comment subscribe
all that stuff helped me out I'd love to
know what tricks you've found to
incorporate lots of different training
methods all into a single program and
yeah I'll see you next time bye for now